[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission où nous
allons vous faire découvrir un festival
qui aura lieu du premier au 4 juin
prochain à villède avec celui qui en est
l'âme et le directeur artistique Vincent
précieux bonjour bonjour alors on va
parler de vous après de votre carrière
de pianiste mais vous êtes un habitant
de Vilaine depuis quelques temps et vous
avez décidé d'y créer un festival et
alors on va tout de suite commencer par
un des spectacles qui aura lieu je crois
que c'est le samedi soir samedi soir
avec avec notamment Christophe Barbier
bonjour Christophe bonjour Patrice
bonjour Vincent bonjour à tous alors ce
spectacle c'est chose de vu et chanter
chose vu
évidemment on pense à Victor Hugo et ses
Victor Hugo mais alors Victor Hugo avait
dit il y a cette phase buse phrase ne
déposez pas de musique sur mes verres
et pourtant heureusement il y a des
musiciens qui n'ont pas écouté qui n'ont
pas suivi et c'est heureux alors
racontez-nous un peu ce spectacle
est-ce que spectacle est né d'abord d'un
texte dans ce formidable chose vu c'est
10000 pages de notes prises à la volée
par Victor Hugo où il consigne ses
observations politiques sociales ce
qu'il voit dans la rue ce qu'il vaut
aussi dans ses rêves parce que vous
savez qu'il était hanté quand même par
les esprits par les morts et tout cela a
donné des mises à l'année comme on dit
absolument prodigieux on peut puiser
dedans des aphorismes de très longs
textes le retour des cendres de Napoléon
par exemple en 1840 ou bien de longs
développés politiques sur le Second
Empire et la dictature donc moi j'ai
choisi j'ai picoré dans ce monument de
d'écriture que sont chose vues et puis
nous avons tissé quelque chose autour
des poèmes qui en effet ont été mis en
musique par les compositeurs qui ont
trahi la volonté de Hugo mais quel
compositeur parce que quand vous avez
Franz Liszt forêt Verdi et quelques
autres pouvaient penser que la trahison
est quand même assez prodigieuse et
justement donc vous êtes accompagné dans
ce spectacle par Pauline Courtin qui qui
chante qui sont les donc
ces compositions faites sur les sur les
poèmes de Victor Hugo et puis et avec
Antoine Palo au piano c'est ça
tout à fait voilà le trio que de que
nous formons pour faire partager la
prose et les vers de Hugo
oui c'est ça c'est alors encore vu il a
déjà été joué où il est créé au festival
de Vilaine non nous l'avons promené un
peu partout en France et là nous sommes
très heureux de venir à vilaine au début
du mois de juin pour faire entendre ces
mots vous savez Victor Hugo et décédé le
22 mai 1885 mais il est toujours très
très vivant et pas seulement par les
programmes scolaires la prose de Victor
Hugo les remarques politiques et
sociales de Victor Hugo vous le verrez
si vous venez voir le spectacle elle
raisonne avec l'époque Macron de manière
très insolente
eh bien écoutez ce que je vous propose
c'est de voir un petit extrait du du
spectacle puis on en reparle tout de
suite après
31 mars 1872 il y avait plus qu'un seul
bourreau pour toute la France
il vient de mourir
quand donc la guillotine mora-t-elle
enfer chrétien
du feu en fer païens du feu en fermant
en mettant du feu en faire un doute des
flammes
en croire les religions Dieu est né
rôtisseur
[Musique]
voilà c'est un petit extrait de ce
spectacle là évidemment là enfin rien
que dans cette petite ce petit extrait
on voit en effet la résonance des propos
de Victor Hugo oui sur notre époque
actuelle c'est vrai qu'il a parlé
beaucoup de parler de la peine de mort
mais il y a eu l'Europe et les religions
il y a en effet tous les sujets qui
traversent notre société notre politique
aujourd'hui ont été abordés et de quelle
façon par Victor Hugo oui on voit que
c'est combats sont toujours vivants
parce que quand il écrit ce petit
aphorisme sur la mort du dernier
bourreau en France il faudra attendre
109 ans avant que la peine de mort soit
abolie en 1981 dans notre pays alors que
Victor Hugo était persuadé en février
1848 lors de la Seconde République que
la peine de mort s'était terminée
c'était trop barbare et de même le
combat pour la laïcité éclairée
c'est-à-dire laisser chacun croire en
son Dieu mais n'imposer à personne sa
croyance c'est un combat qui est
toujours d'actualité aujourd'hui à
Téhéran bien sûr mais aussi parfois dans
nos cités
et alors cette forme qui combine à la
fois en effet des textes du goût et puis
vous vous réflexions et puis et puis le
chant avec encore une fois l'excellente
polyn Courtin c'est aussi une façon de
raconter un peu l'histoire de ce
créateurs vous avez fait un autre
spectacle qui se joue actuellement au
Théâtre de Poche le lundi soir sur
Mozart
qui un petit peu la même la même forme
que que celui sur Hugo c'est à dire
qu'on apprend beaucoup de choses et à la
fois on se divertit et puis on entend
quoi on entend des créations formidables
oui j'aime bien essayer de faire passer
un tout petit peu de connaissance un
tout petit peu de d'éducation à travers
le plaisir du spectacle quand on peut
revisiter la vie d'un grand homme
l'oeuvre d'un grand homme ou bien des
événements historiques à travers un
spectacle c'est beaucoup plus ludique et
finalement je suis persuadé que ça reste
beaucoup plus dans les mémoires que de
lire un livre un peu ennuyeux ou
d'assister à un simple cours d'histoire
on avait avec Vincent retraversé mai 68
de la manière cabaret je peux vous dire
que quand vous mettez beaucoup de joie
dans l'histoire contemporaine elle reste
gravée dans les mémoires c'est vrai que
c'était un spectacle c'est absolument
formidable avec avec la musique de avec
Vincent au piano
merci infiniment d'avoir avec nous
Christophe
merci à vous et donc on vous retrouve
samedi c'est le c'est le 3 juin 3 juin à
20h30 à la salle des arts de
Villennes-sur-Seine voilà avec Pauline
Courtin ou Auchan et Antoine Paloc au
piano merci beaucoup
[Musique]
de Victor Hugo
l'occasion parce que Hugo quand il
faisait une tâche d'encre sur un
manuscrit Hugo il en faisait tout de
suite un dessin c'était aussi un gros un
grand graffeur comment dire aujourd'hui
il y a eu des expositions d'ailleurs sur
ces dessins qui sont absolument
formidables merci infiniment et merci et
donc un rendez-vous à Villaines le le 3
juin merci beaucoup Christophe
alors Vincent on va continuer à parler
de ce festival vous en êtes je disais
l'homme enfin le directeur artistique
comment vous avez vu cette idée parce
que c'est le premier c'est la première
édition du festival en fait c'est le
lieu qui m'a inspiré c'est vilaine sur
scène qui est absolument magnifique le
centre-ville ce sont son marché couvert
son église et tout ça tout est tout est
prétexte à la poésie romantisme
d'ailleurs Zola ne s'y était pas trompé
parce qu'il avait sa maison juste à côté
à mes dents voilà qui est juste à 1 km
de Vilaine et donc voilà j'étais fasciné
par ce lieu je me suis dit il va falloir
essayer de faire vivre ce lieu en
musique
vous êtes musicien vous êtes on vous
parlera de de vous tout à l'heure
musique sur scène oui alors ça commence
il y a quatre soirées au fond il y a
quatre quatre soirées exactement il y a
une une journée aussi Qui est qui est
celle du du samedi où il y aura plein
plein d'activités parce qu'en fait le
l'objectif était de faire découvrir de
la musique au sens large c'est à dire on
va de de Michel Berger à Edith Piaf de
la musique sacrée aux airs français du
début du 20e siècle le Real de Anne
Poulenc et tout ça mais il y a aussi de
la musique médiévale par un duo qui
s'appelle Les Baladins il y a du Chantal
plutôt amateur où ils font de la chanson
française et une espèce de enfin pas une
espèce un barnum qui qui lui va faire de
l'éducation ou de l'éveil musical ou les
deux on verra comment ça va se passer
pour les enfants entre les trois et 12
ans on va dire ça d'accord l'idée est de
faire vraiment découvrir
le samedi et le dimanche je voulais
renouer avec une tradition bien
française qui était le thé dansant en
fait les gens adorent ça donc le thé
dansant du dimanche après-midi qui
laissera animé par l'excellent Éric
Bouvelle et Sandra boubel
qui est un duo très connu
en France c'est un accordéoniste
exceptionnel voilà
et ce sera sous le kiosque de Vilaine
absolument tout ça absolument mais alors
vous allez voir c'est du très très haut
niveau c'est vraiment extrêmement bien
joué et chanté par Sandra aussi avec
extraordinaire
alors le premier jour le premier soir
c'est c'est quoi c'est c'est le berger
non voilà c'est un spectacle autour de
l'oeuvre de Michel Berger c'est une une
chanteuse qui s'appelle Sylvia Schmitt
qui est aussi professeur de chant dans
dans la région et qui avait fait un
spectacle il y a quelques années autour
de l'oeuvre de berger et on s'est dit
pourquoi ne pas la reprendre en
ouverture du fait en ouverture du
festival voilà et donc ça c'est le
premier soir ça c'est le premier soir
après donc le samedi donc on parlait de
choses vu et chanter avec Christophe
Barbier euh il y aura juste auparavant
un petit spectacle que je conseille
parce que ça va être très drôle
ça s'appelle le delirium très mince
avec avec j'accès et puis quelqu'un que
je connais bien qui c'est le 24 ans bien
sûr bien sûr alors il faut raconter
j'ai joué l'année dernière
un spectacle sur Pierre Desproges avec
avec
Sylvia Sylvain Catan et Pierreval et
c'est comme ça que on s'est rencontré
absolument parce que
je joue un peu de joue un peu de piano
mais et vous êtes un très grand pianiste
coacher un petit peu
et c'est comme ça qu'on s'est rencontré
il y avait donc il va quatre temps et
Sylvain va être sur cette scène ça ça va
être drôle ça ça va être très très drôle
en fait c'est une c'est une ouverture de
spectacle je me suis inspiré du
spectacle de de
Christophe Barbier et en fait on faire
cette soirée du du samedi autour des
mots m o t S et donc je vais commencer
en disant un poème libertin de la baie
de l'athénian que tout le monde connaît
la culture
vous avez dû beaucoup le mot
et ça va être suivi tout de suite par
par j'accepte immense comédien très
connu dans les années 70-80 la fête
plein plein de films voilà
et ils vont faire tout un propos autour
d'un livre de Jacques serre qui
s'appelle le delirium tremens avec avec
Sylvain Catan qui est drôle il serait
drôle voilà et ils vont enchaîner pour
faire le lien avec le spectacle de
Christophe Barbier avec donc on commence
par le mot et la chose de la baie de la
ténia puis le délirer un trévince puis
un poème qui s'appelle le mot de Victor
Hugo donc ça fait le lien avec ce qui
fait le spectacle et c'est un poème peu
connu mais qui est très très drôle écrit
par victorie voilà alors vous serez vous
sur scène aussi pour un specake qui
s'appelle rencontre voilà c'est ça c'est
ça
qui a lieu quand alors ça c'est le
vendredi soir et ce sera à l'école de de
Breteuil en fait c'est une ancienne
école qui a été repris par un couple que
je salue de Serge et Sophie qui sont des
bénévoles de l'association et qui
permettent à ce festival de voir le jour
et là on va faire ce spectacle rencontre
qui a été écrit par parallèle nebrard
qu'on va à l'écran de méso soprano qui a
fait la
Maîtrise de Radio France excellente
mezzo soprano accompagné par Magali
Laurent au piano qui est une pianiste
classique concertiste exceptionnelle et
moi j'interviens en fait elles vont
elles vont faire toutes les deux des
œuvres de reynaldohann Poulin que voilà
sublime
grandeur de la musique française
absolument absolument je suis absolument
d'accord et elles m'ont fait découvrir
ça et dans le spectacle qui a écrit
Hélène elle voulait absolument faire le
lien d'où le titre rencontre avec les
chansons françaises mais c'est une
chanson française un peu raffinée un peu
classe que j'ai réarrangé très
humblement à la manière de ces grands
compositeurs du début du 20e
par exemple il y aura par exemple les
feuilles mortes dans une dans une
version totalement inédite il y a
L'hymne à l'amour et il y a pour
commencer un jour mon prince viendra
qu'un thème que personnellement je vais
passer complètement pour un garçon fleur
bleue mais j'adore ce thème c'est des
une écriture exceptionnelle et voilà
c'est un gros succès je crois pendant la
guerre parce que parce que les femmes
sont des femmes parce que les il y avait
des hommes qui étaient emprisonnés en
Allemagne et un jour mon prince viendra
il va revenir voilà c'est ça c'est
absolument voilà d'attente et peut-être
de résistance oui donc ça ça va être un
specte un magnifique spectacle
oui alors vous êtes c'est facile de
monter un festival comme ça puisque
c'est le premier alors non c'est pas
simple c'est pas simple c'est pas ça
mais la chance que j'ai c'est de
connaître beaucoup d'artistes et qu'ils
m'ont fait confiance en fait ça c'était
vraiment la la grande chance de cette
première édition du festival ils m'ont
suivi les yeux fermés on dit quoi là
avec toi on va on va t'aider à monter ce
premier festival et ça c'est
extraordinaire et quand on a les
artistes alors ce n'est pas tout mais
forcément ça ça stimule terrible
c'est vrai que vous arrivez à un moment
où la question des finances des communes
se posent elles sont de plus en plus
réduites donc souvent c'est
malheureusement la culture
grave
ouais c'est bien que justement de c'est
pour ça qu'il faut soutenir absolument
ce genre d'initiative alors parlons un
peu de vous
ça là je suis beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins habile non parce que alors il faut
dire bah par exemple je pense que
beaucoup de gens ont vu une pièce
formidable qui a eu un succès dingue qui
s'appelait foufou contrôle les Bains
alors c'était
un spectacle absolument réjouissant
quelle durée des années des années va
jouer en deux fois on la joue au début
des années 2000 je l'ai vu au début je
l'ai revu après et là on l'a joué
vraiment on l'a joué plus de 10000
Molière on a eu un Molière la première à
la première comment dire la première
édition on va dire ça et on a eu une
nomination Molière en 20202 me
semble-t-il 2022
l'auteur de pièces absolument
irrésistible
et donc vous vous avez écrit et jouer
sur scène la musique de cette pièce
absolument pas que j'étais le directeur
musical donc j'ai réarrangé des des
thèmes les thèmes que que Patrick
voulait et j'en ai écrit quelques-uns
donc il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
chansons de de villemetz comme mon homme
tel qu'il est enfin des choses que tout
le monde connaît et au milieu de ça j'ai
aussi voilà glissé quelques compositions
un beau succès le piano est venu comment
dans votre vie
oulala il est venu relativement tard oui
relativement tard parce que mon mon père
voilà vous m'avez eu des déboires avec
la musique voulait pas tellement que je
sois musicien voilà donc j'ai commencé
tard et j'ai fait mes vraiment toutes
sortes de choses du
très jeune j'ai fait du bal puis j'ai
fait beaucoup de concerts puis le je
crois que mon art de prédilection on va
dire c'est le c'est le spectacle musical
parce que c'est ça mêle tellement
d'activités j'adore ça j'adore mais vous
avez
le conservatoire de en Suisse voilà je
fais un conservatoire à Fribourg j'ai
fait une école de musique aux États-Unis
enfin voilà j'ai un peu et vous avez
accompagné beaucoup de beaucoup de
chanteurs
alors dans les chanteurs de variétés pas
énormément mais j'ai eu de la chance de
de par exemple de compos une chanson qui
a été chantée par Barbara Hendricks ou
une chanson chantait pas alors en Europe
elle est un peu moins connue mais elle
est extrêmement connue aux États-Unis en
Amérique latine qui une dame une femme
qui chanteuse qui s'appelle Lila dawns
qui a gagné deux greniers au hard enfin
voilà bon j'ai eu de la chance j'ai fait
c'est la composition qu'ils attire plus
que la scène ou aller d'eux je crois que
le la pendant les deux confinement j'ai
beaucoup composé du coup j'étais
beaucoup dans dans ma cave vous avez un
studio ouais vilaine mais le la scène
manque forcément on est content de
remonter sur scène
il y a des projets dans il y a plein
plein de projets dont un avec notre
Sylvain Catan qui la science en
spectacle un peu plus sérieux qui va
être autour de de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et d'un d'une personnalité peu
connue que l'histoire a peu connue peut
dans l'histoire se rappelle peu en fait
c'est il y a le marshard qui a été le
président de la
reichbank voilà il est un peu collaboré
la montée d'Hitler au pouvoir enfin
voilà là c'est un spectacle un petit peu
plus compliqué et puis je remonte sur
scène avec Marthe Keller là c'est aussi
une grande joie voilà
pour un spectacle
et puis elle est adorable
qui est une lecture autour de la poésie
de Pablo Neruda d'accord parce qu'en
fait il est très connu pour son
engagement politique mais c'est un pote
avant tout un poète absolument humaniste
exceptionnel et donc là on a j'ai des
amis latino-américains exceptionnelles
qui qui m'accompagne sur scène Francisco
Gonzalez et Nelson Gomes qui sont
incroyables et on fait des des
compositions
des compositions originales on en
espagnol et on reprend certains thèmes
super connus latino-américains et tout
ça entre mêlé par les par les le fil
rouge étant la poésie de Neruda voilà ça
ça va être génial c'est pour quand ça
alors ça on le joue en Suisse pour
l'instant d'accord
au mois de septembre
et comment ma vie
elle est tellement adorée non c'est vrai
mais c'est quelqu'un de c'est une vraie
personnalité c'est quelqu'un de quand je
dis adorable c'est quelqu'un qui a du
caractère mais qui est très respectueuse
de voilà de de ces de ses collègues sur
scène elle est très facile à travailler
enfin voilà on fait vraiment
une belle équipe alors là on est à une
quinzaine de jours de de musique sur
scène
comment comment vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit là vous avez un peu les les
bah un petit peu toujours un petit peu
et là on est on est on est à fond j'ai
une équipe de bénévoles extraordinaire
extraordinaire je vais les citer si ça
vous ennuie pas bien sûr Carmen Fiona
Isabelle Sophie Nadia il y a Serge
j'espère de ne pas oublier Frédéric
Stéphane Hervé Christina enfin voilà
tout ces gens que je remercie c'est des
gens de vilaines qui eux aussi voilà ils
ont ils ont adhéré à mon idée tout de
suite tout de suite bien sûr on est avec
toi c'est ça qui est génial dans une
ville c'est quand on arrive à mobiliser
comme ça des gens et des bénévoles
notamment sur des événements sur un
événement culturel comme celui-là c'est
c'est c'est formidable et je voulais si
vous me permettez ajoutez quelque chose
parce que j'ai complètement oublié je le
vois sur la fiche c'est l'ensemble
myriade qui est un ensemble vocal
amateur et eux aussi on est on est allé
assister à la répétition parce que
l'idée c'était aussi de mêler les
amateurs et les professionnels
ça c'est formidable et là en fait ils
font ils font de la musique plutôt de la
musique sacrée de la musique compliquée
voilà sacrée et ils ont ils ont un
engagement qui nous a qui nous a
beaucoup touché
Magali Laurent et Hélène Brar et
moi-même on est allé assister à une
répétition ils sont mais géniaux c'est
incroyable l'énergie l'abnégation qui
met dans le dans leur dans leur ensemble
vocale et donc on a mêlé les les deux
artistes et les Nebra et Magali Laurent
qui vont venir chanter et les
accompagner avec eux ça va être un
moment magique et ça c'est le dimanche
juste avant le thé dansant
ça va être à 15h30 à la salle des arts
voilà bon ben donc on sait où il faut
être entre le premier et le 4 juin c'est
à Vilaine
merci merci
beaucoup bravo pour merci de m'avoir
initiative et voilà et puis on vous dit
merde quoi on prend on prend on prend
merci beaucoup merci merci
[Musique]